so hello we won to this panel first of
all thanks so much everyone to make it
here and also for debate my data
organizers for making the panel happen
so when when Katrina asked me to do a
panel on ethical machinery and I got
super excited and so glad that we could
do this I think it's a it's super fun to
do this together with also talks and
things like this to mix things up a
little bit so hopefully we can learn
from this and start to to be
experimental in the way we organize our
PI data events and try out interesting
ways of sharing knowledge and ideas and
etc so so my name is Lucy I run a
company creative the day I am that's
basically it you can find more about me
on graphic one of the worst possible
nicknames on Twitter but it's there you
can find it and with me I have Andreas
so Andreas maybe you want to go first
ahead you cannot hear me should I talk
louder so let's start off with our first
so so the question I'll ask everyone is
like can you shortly tell me who you are
what you do and maybe something else you
want to share with your own so okay I'm
andreas I'm originally a trained
physicist I've been working at the data
scientist for the last four years so I
spend 50% of my time working at a
spin-off of for like large German
corporation called the German
cybersecurity organization what I do
there is I try to analyze Network data
to find anomalies and make company
networks more secure and the other half
of my time I spend at my own startup
seven scientists and what we're trying
to do is to build data tools that make
it easier for individuals and small
companies to analyze their data and
securely share it with others yeah and
I'm also very interested in of course
everything that is connected to ethics
and machine learning especially
questions involving the fairness and how
we can train algorithms such that we can
be sure that we have like a societal
benefit from the results cool so next we
have my Ragosa from buddha yang welcome
hello hello so my name is Mario Casas
I'm from Prague and I have two companies
one is keen software house where we are
developing video games such as space
engineers and the other company and
that's why I'm here is a good AI where
we are developing general artificial
intelligence and general means basically
AI that can or in the end I will be able
to learn like people and create other
AIS
and basically improve itself hello okay
my name is a house walls Parvati I'm
organizing PI data apart not tidied up a
lady in Montreal Canada and I'm also
leading a data science team in a company
called Shopify and yes that's what I do
so what do i do all day I'm also a
physicist so I've been working in the
industry for the last two-and-a-half
years and my interest with machine
learning ethics it's more around so I
feel like the company where I am is
growing a lot and we're increasingly
using machine learning and there's all
these horror stories that you see on
Twitter and the media's and I just want
to make sure that and the algorithms
that we produce are you know not
propagating and yeah discriminatory
practices
yeah good afternoon Berlin I'm Henry
Coyle I'm a researcher with the
University of Bremen and my field is
human-computer interaction so I'm
actually not looking at how machine
learning works but what it means what it
means to the people that interact with
it so this is about the usability of
machine learning and especially Trust
why do people trust when do people trust
and how can we measure that and what I
like about this panel about the
situation in university we think a lot
about fairness accountability and bias
and machine learning but you actually
the people who can make the difference
right we can't have nice theories we can
reason about it but
if you're the person to implement it you
can actually make the cause I'm really
excited to talk a bit about the issues
we've been discussing in a more academic
setting
well I feel very honored to sit up here
my name is Katherine Jarl and I helped
organize the Khadija Berlin conference
here and when I'm not doing volunteer
time things I run a data science
consulting company here in Berlin or I
work with clients on some of these
problems my background is a little bit
more as like a Python hacker an
experimenter and because of this when I
first started doing machine learning and
natural language processing I mean it we
started to want to hack around and see
what it was doing behind the scenes and
could I understand it and interpret it
and see if I could break it and through
some of this experimentation I found
some really ugly things and this made me
care very deeply about how we as applied
data science outside of the research
elements how we can really think about
fairness in our models this was my
introduction to this field cool so for
the first question so let's first define
what we're talking about AI so let's
define AI just anything which we see as
the kind of computers making decisions I
think that's that's very simple first
thing to target so any any kind of
algorithm or anything which makes
decisions based on human data human
produced data and on in that regard
maybe you can start with like what are
we since we're talking about so many
things which go wrong and so many things
which should go better what are we
actually excited about so what are the
things we're actually very happy about
that is happening in the field over
maybe the last couple of years
I'm doing answers um
so personally I mean as that is my talk
I'm more optimistic and pessimistic when
it comes to machine learning because I
think like today we have so many
processes that are run like by humans so
to say and that contain a lot of
problems like biases criminy
and if we now like take all of that and
like are able to like turn it into like
semi-automated or lightly supervised
processes using machine learning I think
we have a large chance of actually
making many of these things better you
know because it's not the case that we
don't have any discrimination for
example in hiring in like deciding who
can do business reform and who gets
admitted also to a university nothing by
using AI we have a large potential of
actually making all of these things more
fair for everyone and in general I'm
like especially in the last five years I
think like everyone else here really
impressed at what especially deep
learning and like neural networks has
achieved in like not only creative AI
but in many specialized domains whether
they are already better than humans so
I'm personally really excited to see
what will happen in the next 10 or 15
years in which order things that today
we think might be really difficult or
impossible to do with such a system
might become commonplace actually so my
take on would be that I see or like what
makes me happy is that AI and AI safety
ethics and all these things are becoming
kind of mainstream and even the general
AI field which was kind of niche and
maybe even like the bedside of AI
because it was too optimistic to to you
know like people trying to do something
which other people consider impossible
is becoming I would say kind of like
mainstream even though many people don't
call what they are working on generally
I but from our perspective is actually
general because it added is not only
focusing on very specific tasks or
designs or like very specific domains
but AI that can actually improve itself
or AI that can transfer knowledge from
one domain to another or edit can design
another is so basically every month I am
like s times going I am more and more
surprised how many people are working on
AI and how is it opening and even
started ed for example a year ago I was
kind of unhappy because many of the
progress that I've seen in AI machine
learning deep learning where from my
perspective just like very narrow thing
and just one year passed and I see all
these articles papers and everything and
it's like really doing the universal
stuff for growing in this general
direction so that really makes me happy
so something that really makes me happy
in them and what's happening with regard
to algorithm fairness is to see that
people are getting organized for some
things like instead of the thing IO
algorithms are mean people are actually
doing very very nice things and I want
to give a shout out to the algorithmic
just this league and like their way of
you know fighting against some
discrimination in our life's a face
recognition software is to create a
better training set with so if you don't
know the service so some some people
with darker skin tone don't get
recognized by face recognition
algorithms and one way to address that
is to actually have a better data set so
people are getting organized to create
better data sets that are more inclusive
and more diverse and I think this will
benefit the whole machine learning
community yeah what I think is crazy if
we really think back that we have
something like Google is pretty amazing
you know we can really search most of
the books and we can find so many things
with a fingertip that's pretty amazing
and self-driving cars and all these
advances I could have easily imagine
that being 15 15 years further down the
road we will see how quickly will
actually write in one back home and
these kind of things but what I really
like about AI at this point is that this
open-source
ethos did survive to some extent we have
archive we have get hive and if you look
for instance at face app that was like
really cutting edge research a year ago
and now you can buy you can just get the
app on the App Store and play with these
kind of models it's pretty amazing and
unique just how quickly and I open this
is still happening even though there's
the room to the top
I think for me and I know that this is a
sentiment that several folks in the
conversations we've had prior to have
said is that sometimes we can use this
AI now to actually counter our own
biases so one company that I came across
that's doing a really amazing job is
they're able to you hook them up
basically to management emails to teams
and when they see that you're unfairly
distributing work let's say somebody
gets a really big project and another
team another member of the team gets
only small little tasks they're never
assigned larger projects it can actually
send you a little reminder and say hey
you know Joanna hasn't received an
important project in two weeks
can you please you know send her one and
these types of things where AI can
actually help us make decisions right
this goes back to the origins of AI and
these decision support systems we can
build them to actually help counter our
own biases as humans then I think we can
really have some better reactions to
this you know kind of computer assisted
decision-making cool so they don't do
positive notes so I mean there's a lot
of points to touch upon here but one of
the points come going back with Hendrik
you made about data at Google and data
so AI is also called a new electricity
by engineering and it's also called data
is the new oil so maybe anyone here
wants to comment on that like what what
does it mean when we have so much data
in the world and make it accessible to
machine learning algorithms like is that
good is that what will happen mr.
different situations where we should
think about every hundred can go three
yeah basically from an academic
perspective there's a really nice paper
that basically social science always had
big data you know there's like lack of
data was never a problem for many
scientific disciplines and it's really
the interpretation and
the context realization of this data
that matters and I think that that's
truer than ever in a way especially with
more data because more is not
automatically better if you look at for
instance this Google Flu trend project
where they're basically said we have
search engines results and see what
people are looking at looking for we can
predict whether people have two flu and
where that look really promising but
then when terribly bad and just
completely over fitted on the data
relates to that also when we talk about
data or more about making things more
accessible to everyone so there is a
kind of wave which I'm very excited
about about making more machine learning
problems and models and data accessible
to more people our kids get skies and I
predict I'm running many binder is
another I find in notebooks being shared
everywhere becoming more accessible so
what are the dark sides of all that
sharing like again great yes we're all
sharing things with each other but what
does this democratization mean anyone go
into it I can start one fear that I have
is a fear that I notice sometimes with
programmers that I work with is the copy
and paste mentality and I would say this
like well it was my top result on Stack
Overflow or was my top result on github
I'll just plug it in with my data and it
will just work right I mean if it's in
the sidekick learning samples or if it's
in these examples for how to use this
library what could go wrong and I think
a deeper understanding our conversation
about exactly how we choose to do that
and exactly how we then choose to allow
that to enter our products or into more
customer-facing interfaces then that
becomes a really big concern because if
I haven't really been thoughtful about
what data I'm going to introduce why am
i choosing this exact algorithm versus
another or why this arc
why does it work then we don't have a
good indicator of when it's going right
and when it's going wrong we just say oh
yeah it's doing something
it looks intelligent I will just keep
doing this and I am so much fearful of
this problem I mean related to data
singles of points you made transfers
about these are experts who are working
every day with algorithms and data and
the purpose is what you know we can
decide what your rules are that we want
to have in our companies when we build
products or in your research faculties
and that's like 0.1 which i think is
it's already kind of again we can make
having kind of code of conducts or
Hippocratic oaths for data scientists
and something that's like again like
awesome that Shopify is doing that for
instance but what about when we offer
our services to users as an API or as a
service where models are trained and
it's actual everyday users who might not
know implications of their the data
they're plugging into these systems
maybe some thoughts on to say something
I know that yeah I'm so I see this
trainer at conferences like boots of
companies that offer AI as a service and
this is all great because a lot of small
companies all cannot afford a whole data
science theme but I feel that there's we
just need to be cautious or at least at
these companies like know so let's say
you know their value proposition is that
they have a lot of data they train
models it's a language modeled and then
they offer their API to a lot of
companies what if this word embedding
model is bias isolated sexist for some
reason and an customers don't know it I
feel I mean I don't have all the answers
but it I think they need to be
transparent and that the end user can
ask them questions about like okay it is
it okay to use your service for this and
use because let's say that you're using
a sexist or however discriminatory model
to do things like you know rank jobs for
people for instance then you're offering
opportunities to people based on
attributes that have nothing to do with
their skills but with things that have
to do with other dimensions of diversity
like their gender or their ethnicity so
I think that when we consume this sort
of API we it's on us to ask the question
you know it is this working in the way
that I want it to work and there are
things you can do because you control
the inputs that you are sending and the
outputs that you are receiving so you
can use your own and an association
matrix package or something to to figure
out if you don't have like where things
happening there but I think the services
should also be aware of this and that if
there's something wrong with their model
to change it because they are a very key
player where they can have this huge
impact on a lot of other companies that
are using their services actually I
would be super happy to hear about
someone who work for such a company to
know what they see yeah what would they
think about this but there's none on
this panel I think so on the blog of
like asking questions like magic since
you work with like more long-term AI and
specifically as well like what what are
the main questions we should ask another
thing AI now looking into the future
mm-hm I would say what is the value
system that this AI should have what
what are its preferences and I think
it's quite natural that the creator of
the AI system the teacher the mentor
will want to imprint its own value
system to the to the AI plus then there
is also some laws and things like that
and relate to the previous question you
know the access to all this data via I
would also like want to say a different
approach and it's like we actually can
generate a lot of data because we can
create virtual environments and like can
generate as much data as you want it's
kind of like interactive data and so we
tend to think about this like curricula
so what kind of learning tasks or
correct curricula we want to have our AI
and to positively by us each actions you
know and also its understanding of the
world so in our work especially in the
long term planning because it's not a
current issue but in long term we plan
to have a we call it school for AI which
will be curricula with many learning
tasks from very basic to more complex
the day I will be learning like one task
after another and using the learned
skills heuristics or whatever we call it
to learn the other more efficiently and
also while doing this it will be
positively biased towards understanding
the world in similar manner SV people
understand the world and also biasing
its actions in a positive direction so
that's basically our plan and then at
the end of the day of course we'll have
to test it you know in some kind of
sandbox environment where the AI will
not know that it's actually being tested
and to make sure that its actions are
really what we wanted to do so we don't
want to have a black book system
basically then the thinks is also maybe
to the question of like who should
decide on the properties AI should have
is it us as engineers when we develop in
our systems and we think okay we want a
model not to be sexist meaning we we as
engineers will make a definition of that
and we'll test our model for that or she
is actually be a wider agreed upon
concern the decision within society
which can be be debated which can be
maybe even block and complain or
legislated if I make there is already
like many laws you know
anti-discrimination and all these things
and there is also a new regulation
coming next year and on the other side
I'm not sure if it's possible to really
enforce you know
like that all the AIS will oblige these
to these regulations or these consensus
but I'd like we should try of course and
yeah yeah and I think like people in
certain societies they have these
consensus what is good what is wrong and
they usually like put these two to those
so that's how I think it will get to the
AI yeah also don't see like the
engineering side of this driving so to
say the rules by which the system should
work it's like for me a societal
political decision and they are from
anything thing that is said already
existing laws I think especially
concerning the privacy and like data
processing of personal data it will get
better than it is today with the
regulation next year the European Data
Protection Directive and I think in
other areas just like a self-driving
cars for example and you can also see
that they are efforts from the
government to think about these problems
you know they've been like the report of
the commission of the ethical Commission
on self-driving cars that was released
one months ago and which tries to answer
also like difficult questions like the
trolley problem you know can like a
system decide to kill one person to like
save a number of other persons and so I
don't think that is something that
engineers should decide on their own so
that really must be a broader decision
and this question really strikes a chord
with me because I make in exactly that
situation and I I feel that I mean it
starts with us right we are the the
frontline we are the ones coding the
algorithms and so it it just happens
that we are the ones making those
decisions but then you know from the
ground up you talk with the people in
your organization and you try to figure
out like because like if I think that
the threshold for you know some variable
related to say data privacy or for
discrimination
maybe my colleague that's sitting right
beside me as a different opinion so I
feel like we should reach some
consistence inside the our organization
and then also it's a very healthy thing
to have this public discourse around all
of this
and also I feel that laws are ways a
little bit late after the technology so
since we're already there we should
maybe inform what the next laws will be
about so from start here you're making a
point that we should be before the laws
we should kind of yes I don't I don't
think because it's it's always so
painful and there's a new line then you
have like to change you know you have to
to swipe your your database and start
another one and scrub all the private
information from there well like if you
think about those things in the first
place
you will be in a much better place when
there's a law that will you know
actually be angry with you for for the
things that you're doing so we should be
proactive I feel but also answering that
question who is supposed to decide that
I think who will decide we already know
that we already have it in place right
we have political systems and everybody
can participate and make themselves so
and it's really we have good protection
for privacy and these kind of things
it's on to us to enforce them and also
also to be critical engineer's building
systems to say okay this is against the
law and as also escalating that up
because we're very fortunate right even
if you kind if we're not completely at
the mercy of our employees right we will
find a job because we're engineers and
everybody needs program is at this point
of time so basically it's up to us to
just for instance nice example is this
discrimination on Facebook right there
are many many laws and you
discriminating against people who want
to run from your house it's not allowed
but if you then just take things that
correlate for instance with race or
gender or sexual orientation you can
again advertise to certain people which
you would never be able to do in a
newspaper you can't say okay I want
white heterosexuals to work in my
apartment can't do that if you do ads on
Facebook you can easily do that why I
mean why didn't they have like things in
place to prevent that it's easily
preventable I heard a sentiment that we
definitely need to have some of the
first steps forward
I was able to attend part of undresses
talk today and I think one difficult
thing that we have here is how do we
measure these things how do we evaluate
them and since there is at this point in
time not a lot of consensus about how to
do that well we have this problem yes I
would like to build more ethical AI but
how do I indeed measure that and make
sure that I am measuring with a similar
standard to you at your company I'm not
saying that we need to standardize
everything but we need to have public
conversations about how we're doing it
internally within our own organizations
so perhaps we can create better
standards across the board rather than
just each little pocket has their own
determination of what is unfair
treatment which would be really
problematic in the end then if a
regulation comes down and just decides
that it's X Y or Z I don't it only fits
one particular problem so we still 15
minutes and then we'll open it up to the
room also for for questions but to go a
little bit further on the topic of
privacy and legislation and data but
what about the current business models
which are in place with companies where
we all work where there are already
systems were which are proven to be
inherently discriminatory in the bath
some stuff in the machine learning some
combustor is the system for recidivism
rates in the US which was mentioned in
the keynote talk this morning but their
argument would is would be or energy is
that this is proprietary information the
trade secrets etc so you can't really
question these systems exact set by
using them well the counter-argument
would be yes that's totally true of
course this company cannot give you no
access to their proprietary you know
technology to everyone because people
will just copy paste it in there but
they would be out of business so what
could we do the sentiment they're like
well how can we find kind of the good
balance between having working business
models and companies can still make
money but at the same time also be hold
accountable
I think we have many systems in place
again that ordered companies or
companies get certified to basically
follow certain laws and I think we just
need to and this is again up to us to
tell the people who make the laws what
is needed and where the risk because
they might pretend should not see them
but if we see them we just kind of have
to reach out I would say so I think data
is like a huge part of the problem and
so far it's really as you said that the
user really difficult to get my data
from a company I can try you know in
Germany there's some people that try to
get their Facebook data but it's a very
long process and the company can like
help the longer arm so to say they don't
have to give you the data if they don't
want to and if this really changes next
year I mean it's my hope that it changes
then it will make it much easier to
actually say hey please give me all my
data and let me have a look at that and
then you can see it can pull that data
with the data from other people and like
try to reverse engineer at least some of
the algorithms and then see if there are
some bias and I think that would already
help a lot and if that's they're not
enough to keep companies from doing
things which are clearly like herding
groups of people then I think one should
like think about more about regulation
you know like some areas today
where they're high risks in gambling for
example are also areas where there's a
lot of regulation and data science or
like algorithms are so far very little
regulated maybe deceptive to have to
change in the future
but it would be of course better if the
companies by themselves would like open
up their algorithms a bit more in order
to avoid being regulated in the first
place so that's at least my hope which
is a small thing maybe though the models
they I should be more interpretable
explainable and that will make it also
easier for the third party to to believe
or trust in what the AI is doing how
much or if it is biased and so on and I
think just echoing some of these
sentiments if the consumer the end-user
right who is maybe not aware of what
data is available not aware that they
are being recommended
particular search results rather than
their friends the more that there is
consumer awareness I think the more that
there will be a push from the business
side to build something that is slightly
more transparent and I think if we maybe
this is perhaps some of my American
background coming in but if we can make
a financial incentive to have more
transparency and more ethical treatment
of data then it becomes harder to say no
when these large corporations have you
know so much data on us I argue for a
carbon tax on ethical data description
data tech that's an excellent idea so
what about research like what kind of
research is happening but what kind of
research should maybe be happening both
in academia as well as maybe in research
centers commercial research centers
anyone has any ideas like what should be
the things we really should spend more
time on I have an answer on the opposite
like what kind of research shouldn't
happen because some things and we talked
about this earlier I think in Germany
we're very fortunate in that we for
instance decided to again using
computers in voting just because we said
this is such fundamental technology that
everybody it should be transparent that
everybody should understand it and I
think we should also just look for these
kind of things that we don't want to
touch and this could be voting but this
could easily also be the decision
whether somebody stays in jail or not
that we could just exclude that from an
algorithmic decision making more ideas
about what should or should not be
researched for I mean one one thing
magic you mentioned the more
interpretable models I think that's a
clear thing where there is more research
and I think a result of research coming
into this area recently so I think that
can recover you know at least on the
research
right and I cannot think about any field
that is not being researched they know
about just of course the question is
what is the progress for this the state
and and so on but I think there are
people who are researching the long term
things shorter things safety ethics you
know then like the AI architectures so I
think it's all covered and maybe yeah
maybe one thing that kids actually like
others being at Gudea is that we spend a
lot of time on doing road maps and Road
mapping and maybe it doesn't sound like
the most important thing but when you
are actually working on some road map
you need to think about what are the
states or the director actors what are
the actions of these actors what are
their motivations and so on and you can
start playing these games and you will
come up with different scenarios and
then you can start thinking about how to
mitigate you know this stage like for
example if these actors will do these
these days then this third actor will
react in this way and if it is a bad
action then how can the other actors
mitigate these action big before it
happens and so for example one of the
things that we are also working on is a
irise avoidance which is like it's more
long-term thing but in the future when
there will be few companies that will be
really getting close to this general AI
it can get like really hot you know and
the the need to be first with this
general AI may be bigger than the safety
issues you know so they make like there
may be in balance between how fast they
want to go forward there is how safe
they want to go there and I don't think
there is a solution to this because if
the motivation to be the first will be
huge you know then like the Ruby someone
will just go despite any risks and so I
think research on how to actually
practically solve these issues I think
it's very really irrelevant as well
and so a lot of the academic research
that I've read is you know is great and
all of that but it always starts with we
assume that we have data about discuses
variables and it just happens that where
I'm working right now we don't ask
people for their gender their sexual
orientation their age their ethnicity
they're just merchants that use Shopify
to sell stuff online and one of the
things that I struggle with is like how
do I infer this not to sell something to
those people but to just make sure that
my algorithms are not being
discriminatory in a way that I could not
detect otherwise so the kind of things
that I would like to see more of is how
can I infer like how can I solve this
dilemma like how can I not collect
necessarily more data about the users
but making sure that you know they get
the fair treatment from the algorithms
just a chime in I would echo definitely
on the interpretability aspect and the
fact that sometimes I feel like we are
in a bit of a hype cycle where we are
more excited about something that can
learn something very fast and in a very
perhaps deep architecture then we are of
our ability to diagnose if it goes wrong
or so I think that this is one and
another one that is becoming more of a
passion of mine is how can we break more
of these algorithms so can we do
research on how to fuzz and break and
make our models do bad things the more
that we understand how to do this the
more we can probably a build better
models and be you know be a little bit
more aware of you know like more of the
security hacker approach towards AI a
machine learning than just how do I make
the best model that will never break
how do we break more things I would
totally echo that braking algorithms
more but also get his name into the last
part like what are other things that we
can do just in our everyday work as
working with algorithms or machine
learning models like how could we work
to suppress kind of this knowledge in
the best possible way to make it a more
societal based discussion or make it
more accessible to people as well as
inherently these systems play a big role
in society and therefore mumming one
thing breaking them makes always good
for good stories as well which is always
a plus point maybe doing the opposite so
one project I used to run with it with a
collaborator of mine was doing the worst
possible thing we can think of with
machine learning and over it as a
service but then we were just about to
launch it there was actually a company
doing it so hard like what what else
what could be things which could gonna
help us rethink machine learning despite
the imagination so I think a lot of the
problem today with machine learning is
that for the general populations of
people that are not working in this
field it's still really hard to
understand for once what can be done
with their data and how the algorithms
below the surface actually work so I
think it would be a good investment to
like try to explain better not to a
technical audience but to like people
that use these systems what exactly is
in the data points that they're sending
you know like because the most it means
myself included I also don't always have
like an idea of what you can do with
just like a few GPS coordinates of
myself and Watauga like not maybe
sensitive information you can in fear
from that and like teaching people more
about that and like putting them in a
better position to judge if they should
give for example an app or software
access to some of their data I think
that would be already a big step in the
right direction because when people
could decide them says what they want to
do today it's mostly like okay you
install something and you like take you
accept the consequences that it has
but you don't know really what you're
doing so and I think really that would
really be make a big effect more than
like trying to get a better like
technological grasp on the problem just
like getting the general population
better educated about this and maybe the
also like the unsexy academic answer is
just to be critical and to look really
deeply into these systems and just try
to understand and because if you really
look at how were Tyvek works it's no
surprise that it would just have these
biases because it just takes them from
the data you look at image captioning
and image captioning a lot of the verbs
a lot of the adjectives are just
inferred because if you have a picture
of a talk and a frisbee there's only so
many things it can reasonably do with it
so there's only five words and one will
probably dominant so you'll be playing
with it and you see these TED Talks
where people say like yeah we have soft
computer vision we understand images
while in reality we're not even close
their eyes and just be critical and just
but also play with it and hack it and
fuzz it a thing it's very nice yeah cool
one more Lost's before we open it up to
the audience well I would instead ask
you to share a little bit more because I
find your work to be kind of
inspirational in this if you care to I
know you're speaking later but for the
yeah so so I work with a lot of kind of
creative applications of AI and I think
that one of the so of course we do all
kinds of things which are actually
useful for our clients for designers but
next to that we also like to take them
for a swing what we call computational
comedy so we really try to kind of find
interesting properties and try to
enlarge them kind of make them make them
bigger and by that it's a bit like not
necessarily completely breaking these
models but at least like bending them
which is done very interesting so it's
another way of building done more
interpretive models because it
inherently tells you something about the
model like a deep dream at Google was
born that way right it was an experiment
where people just played around with
this kind of your classification models
and started to get very interesting
weird things they couldn't
stand and just started to play with it
until it became this big you know MIMO
for the internet but when I just started
my PhD which was you know just then
started around that time a bit before I
actually spend a lot of time on the
dream and everybody which DiNozzo this
guy it's not a private I'm at the
mathematics department so of course
that's not proper to do but it was very
very useful for me to understand
actually much deeper how these models
operate and then being able to do all
kinds of new things with them generative
things so so I know for breaking them
hacking them asking them questions which
may be sound very counterintuitive and
would never work I think it's the people
who are not necessarily educated to most
as engineers who tend to do the most
interesting things with these models
which bring the field further so most of
all for that multidisciplinary research
like having maybe hack parties where
anybody can come by yes I'm the one
machine learning expert right but then
it's like journalists and whoever you
know visualizers cool so then we have so
50 minutes I think there's two two mics
for the room so with 10 minutes 10
minutes so please just shortly say your
name and then just if you want to direct
anyone with a question or just random hi
over here on your left side so my name
is Jonathan Ronan and I used to work in
social science and I work in medical
science and in both of those fields
before err researchers are allowed to do
any study with private data they have to
go through ethics review boards that
ensure that data is properly anonymized
and treated etc a prior to publication
do you envision any way where we force
companies to do this before they deploy
a new data product so what's the
question
the question is why not what how come
this hasn't been done today it seems
like such a no-brainer in academia every
hundred wants to comment as the academic
yeah like a kind like the first thought
was this scandal with Google deep dream
and the NHS where they just use data
that was given to them under a whole
different licensing agreement and just
did something with it I think it's a
understanding problem because you really
need some people who can order it and
can basically make that decision for you
and it's really really complex and it
kind of goes into this proprietary
nature of the things that happen in
companies but you really have to have
people can make that decision reasonably
because you don't want to have an
unsatisfying answer because that will
only slow down good research and you
don't want that situation and you can't
do peer review you know you can't go to
Facebook and say is it okay what Google
is planning here you know the further we
have a problem
hi I'm chip young Okemos FanFest you
want to say something about sorry sorry
so this is a question like why do
companies don't give anonymize datasets
to academia he said how that's how I
kind of understood the question all
right that was specifically my question
was how come we don't force companies to
have ethics review boards it would
approve any data product before they
release it okay well some so nobody's
forcing any companies but some companies
just decide to do it but it would be
nice that it would be forced on everyone
okay yeah I recall a reading an ethical
code of conduct that has been published
by the American Society of software
engineers the document was about 25
years old so maybe we need something
newer - are you aware of any efforts in
that direction nothing actually the ACM
is working on that so they try to do
that as we speak and actually looking
for feedback so if anybody of you wants
to pitch in
you're more than invited I think
everybody can talk there's also one that
interestingly came out of the 2008
financial crisis in the United States
called the financial modelers code of
ethics and some of it is applicable to
this field which is I believe one of
them is I understand that sometimes I do
not know what my model will do and that
the implications of my model functioning
poorly could be massive hi thank you
very much for the interesting panel so
far my name is Valentin and F this
question so in the free software world
there's been an ongoing discussion for a
couple of product decades where they
talk about amending the free software
licenses to a non-military class to
basically disable defense and research
and and all this stuff to make use of
the effort that has been going into free
software by volunteers assuming that a
lot of them will actually be you know
not be ok with their technology's
killing people I feel that in the field
that most people work here it's probably
even more relevant to you know to to
defense applications and you know
regular free software and I was
wondering if there's any discussion or
any you know like ideas to to have a
non-military use in
in agreements of the stuff that we
produce anyone so I know about few
activities or initiatives that are
aiming towards some kind of thing for AI
weapons you know and things like this
and actually recently signed one of
these open letters but I'm still not
really sure if it's possible to been AI
weapons you know like even if you will
have some regulation or something like
this I think the motivation to have air
weapons is so huge that there will be
always some rock actor trying to develop
this in secrecy secrecy or something
like that so I think this is probably
one of the things that needs more
research like how to actually guarantee
that if we do some mitigation action
it's sufficient you know and it's not
just like saying that people please
don't do a weapons and hope that they
will not do you know I think we need
more like some real solid proof or
guarantee I mean that patents are one
way how people tend to do sometimes
these kind of things so it's tends to be
in my experience at least what I know
from my consulting years it does to be
very individual decisions for companies
and sometimes patents help with that so
not at all for the open free software
world so much and I also know many cases
where actually researchers explicitly
didn't want to take research funding
from for military organizations but some
of their research works actually done
even though they doesn't it not to be
used for defense purposes it's always
tends to be hard to know is it being
used since it's always of kind of
classified nature so yeah the chicken
and an egg problem in that dead river
yeah I think big problem is that a lot
of funding comes from the military
especially in the state and one thing to
actually counter that sprinters the
University of blame has a so-called
severe clausal which means we can only
do civil research everybody in the
university people are always trying to
make it weak and it's a constant fight
but we've had it for a while now and I
think it's something that anybody could
adopt if only about sending a message
because I think that's the same with the
open source you know like how would you
know that like some Nora secret military
people are using your software it's
really hard to tell but it's good about
sending a message and it's the same with
export licenses it is possible like I
know of the venture capitalist firms who
take part of their their own something
comes from public organizations in
Germany France is quite common German
CC's who then are not allowed to invest
in anything military or defense so there
definitely should be I mean if there's
some good lawyers in in the room I think
it's a good idea to think about it since
should why not there is a creative
commons which is you know takes a kind
of gradual approach to different things
you can do with free software for
commercial or have you know real mixing
so definitely I think should be possible
hi my name is Emily Grierson skink and
this is a little bit of a direct
question two years ago there is an
article published title is here's why
there ought to be a cap on women
studying science and maths this article
was published by breitbart.com which is
a merchant on Shopify platform how do
you reconcile building machine learning
tools ethically and then using those
tools to support platforms that do the
exact opposite
yeah yeah I don't really want to comment
on this yeah I think maybe one last
question and then okay well I had two
questions one let's say we're just
talking about the ethics not not fixing
machine learning it's not that all the
ethicist and all the population agrees
on deities you have different schools of
thoughts we can just assume that
everybody agrees with each other and
then have our machine learning models
follow those ethical systems it's the
same with the economic system it's not
that everybody the new liberal
capitalist for everybody the socialist
now how do you think we can have
different performance measures following
which optimizing which on machine
learning would subscribe to those
systems a new thing we need that or not
then then you would basically attach an
ideology to your machine learning and
say okay okay my goal is to be a
socialist here or to be a capitalist the
other question is regarding the
anti-discrimination and privacy laws and
personalization okay let's take to the
first question sorry anyone when we
create machine animals do we not imbue
it with an ideology I think it's
fundamentally connects to this idea of
the value alignment problem from
Russells right which basically says that
if we build AI we need to survive as
humans and this is really far out there
we need the machine learning or the AI
to align their values with ours you know
to have the same values I think that's
the same I mean it's learning from data
it's learning all the biases but also
the good things from what's in the data
and we can build on top of that I mean
when you choose like a function that you
want to optimize in your machine
learning system you kind of make a
decision of course what I do I don't
know if I would call it an ideology
because it's more like in most cases at
least a very constricted problem that
you're solving so but of course you're
always making a choice
that also concerns your view on things
like profit versus societal benefit etc
so I think yes but I don't know if we
already had a scale where it really
would net a lot a lot I think in some
cases it really does because as you can
see like news algorithms they can change
or maybe change the outcome of elections
so there you really need to think very
hard how you want to do that in some
areas it's less critical still you know
so but yeah it's definitely something
that we need to think about it
okay cool then just one way to think so
I think this objective function will not
be one singular objective function but
probably made from thousands millions of
smaller ones like local maybe some
here.his and it's actually hard for me
to UM think about this because it's just
like like what is the objective function
of me you know I cannot even define in
my cell like I can to a certain extent
but there will still be so many things
that I will not be able to say and also
maybe there will be some conflicting
objective functions within the global
objective function of the system so I
think this is also one of the very
interesting and not really solved
problems I actually don't agree with the
question I think that is the case if you
cede wider their ideologies attached to
what we do is machine learning
practitioner not only objective
functions but also with data we decide
or don't decide to use but the solution
there's choice right having what is
called interactive machine during or
mixed initiative systems where human and
computer working together and so the
choice is actually with the user which
means that your model has to allow for
certain sense of freedom
allowing choice like having a Google
search engine where you have a slider
saying yes I give all my private data
away versus no I don't want meaning I
don't give private data I have certain
worse search results maybe but let's
filter bubble versus all the way to the
other side yes total filter bubble but
it's made more easy and it's the choice
right which makes it done you know so
you can have different ideologies you
say okay I want the socialist setting or
the annika setting or the capitalist
setting
cool so thanks so much everyone then
we're off to another room for more Q&A
you
[Applause]